[Music]
in news submitter by Lego Bart a bus
company suddenly closed after the boss
fired his entire staff with a bitter
memo dude that sounds like me you would
fire your staff at the memo yeah if I
was just out and I hated everything yeah
no I wouldn't say that would be nice I
have a hard time firing people I fired
myself first huh your fire yep I leave
myself a bitter memo that's right yeah
so this is Sidney Hardy Oh Sidney
he's like a retired Tito Ortiz this is
the memo he sent out to everyone like
this why does it look like he's using
internet from 1993 yeah the subject
reads the end and then the message says
there is a difference between giving up
and knowing when you have had enough I
have had enough and realize I cannot
work with you the people I employ a
moment longer there comes a time in any
relationship when you just have to say
[ __ ] it and say goodbye and move on this
is my time I am quitting to pursue my
dream of not having to work here
nippy bus has ceased operational
activity with immediate effect 29
October 2017 all staff should now
consider themselves dismissed /
redundant the gates are now closed and
will not open so you can stay in your
scratchers Monday and have a lion please
contact the works Mobile on phone number
to arrange collection of any personal
belongings
the company has appointed agents who
will now work to realize the company's
assets and discharge its liabilities you
said [ __ ] life like I'm done I've worked
so much I [ __ ] hate your faces do
ever the [ __ ] you want he's the one that
chose the employees so what the [ __ ] I
hate working with you guys
but you're the one that [ __ ] hired up
you dick face that's true maybe he's
just like done which is working in
general why he's just like [ __ ] he
literally
I'm done working with you yeah is there
responses other members of the company
yeah they're furious and they're like we
have kids like we have mortgages to pay
like we just we didn't even know that
this was coming you're just all of a
sudden you're done so that wasn't even
like a two weeks thing it was like the
next day you guys had same date it's
like we're done there's no two weeks
he's just he's dismembering his whole
company it's just no let this con yeah
and then whatever assets are where
everybody's at owed to him he's gonna
distribute it out that's it so this firm
ran up to 17 buses and they're just
saying that there were over 300 students
across four schools that were affected
by that that they couldn't get to school
or they can't go home
it's just in the US or the UK that is
[ __ ] up I mean I think for me if I was
really tired of any company that I was
dealing with I don't I'm there I could
just drop it like that because I know
people built their lives around it so my
[ __ ] heads up yeah okay man so really
[ __ ] hated his group but he's the
[ __ ] cuz he's the CEO you create the
company culture you're the father figure
that's how it runs like what the [ __ ] do
you like you're blaming your kids for
your company being shitty because as a
as a you stupid garbage can as a human
being you have to do your due diligence
for these people at least because they
depend on you right so even if I [ __ ]
hated all their faces I would just say
hey in about a month I'm gonna liquidate
this company because I [ __ ] hate you
all however I'm not a piece of [ __ ]
human being and I don't want this on my
conscience so I'm gonna give you about a
month ish to two months to figure out
what your next job is so enjoy that go
[ __ ] yourselves I'll miss you why didn't
he why didn't he this like stay hey
you're fired and then just hire a new
round of people he's I don't think he
wants to work I think witnesses he's
done with working can just [ __ ] hire
a GM yeah cuz I I know right like sell
the company how about that there's so
many other options I think that's too
much work
yeah this man
ex-employee of the company had worked
there for almost nine years he said that
it was a disgusting way the way he
handled it nobody had has any respect
for him he was not a nice person to work
with and I he would just like take off
to vacation in Thailand and have other
people do what he's doing in Thailand a
European band boy to Thailand for me I
don't care that he went to Thailand I
did all that [ __ ] yeah well according to
this ex-employee was saying that he knew
months the boss knew months ago that the
company was in trouble in terms of like
how many drivers they had cuz there had
had drivers that were quitting on them
and then the drivers that were working
in the company they had to do longer
shifts to cover and then it was just
like oh you just suck this it just
sounds like a load of garbage he's
obviously a [ __ ] for doing this he's
blaming everybody else but we all know
there's certain people out there they're
just [ __ ] grumpy and they blame
everybody else for their grumpiness and
you just chilling and live in life I had
a professor like this this fool was so
[ __ ] on edge all the time he would be
grading papers right and he'll be
sitting here eating [ __ ] sunflower
seeds and he's like he just thought this
is the wrong wrong wrong and then just
and there's sunflower seeds all over the
[ __ ] exams and just it comes back Bob
Bob dude he sounds like he really cares
no you must care if he's getting that
angry I think as I had a professor in
community ecology cared he looked like
Humpty Dumpty and then people didn't
read what we were supposed to read for
the class these comes as he goes because
all of you don't care about learning you
can all go home and then I got mad
because I said to him what they probably
should I was kind of rude buzz it's like
we don't pay you to care we pay you to
teach so you can't just dismiss us like
that like we they're stupid shame that
[ __ ] did do it in college yeah I was
pissed because that's an ego trip you
know I mean it's like I don't give a
[ __ ] what these other people did you
don't have to do your due diligence and
teach me cuz I'm here I paid for the
[ __ ] we're a smart kid cuz I'll bug ya
my friends you're gonna kick it well I
would say this is Community College so I
have already went to two years River
sighted I transferred over so this is
also available smarter now I'm smarter
at this point too and I was paying for
my own college at this time because
Community College coming out my own
pocket so I was like no you're not gonna
dismiss class I paid for this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] teach me [ __ ] what do you
respond yeah JT [ __ ] you still give this
out and he did not like me for the rest
of the sure but he didn't understand
that [ __ ] you know II mean he just
didn't get like I don't give a [ __ ] what
other people do you still have to do
your job
you hurt me not because you're in a bad
[ __ ] mood [ __ ] did you complain to
all the school no I just sat in class
every day and we just [ __ ] make dirty
looks at each other all the time
did you learn anything in that class no
I still passed up see it you know
there's movies where people are just
like I hate my job
and then like I'm gonna break free yeah
[ __ ] everybody here leave right and
it was like yeah good for you leave that
[ __ ] paper company or whatever but
then if you're a boss doing that no
matter what that's [ __ ] up
ya know there's no good way of doing
that no one's gonna say yeah good for
you liberate yourself it's like don't
[ __ ] I think these people are relying on
you to see their can because the
employee is kind of like alright he's
gonna move off but who does he really
hurt the company's gonna move on without
them by the way Bart you'll have
announcement after this so everybody
stay here we go charity like what if
this were like a midlife crisis where
it's like it's not only just a job it's
like something happen with this kid
something happened with his marriage
something will happen with his parents
it's just this seems like he just blew
up out of nowhere that's what might have
happened I think what really happened
was he went to Thailand conned inside a
hooker
yeah and then fell in love at the same
time yep an STD
exactly and then he like was getting
like he needs to like support that
lifestyle over there yeah he's like [ __ ]
I can't come back to this life with my
wife and all our employees and stuff
like what do I do to make my dream with
the Thailand
a certain money goes a long way over
there
you know maybe well I don't know the
media kept trying to get him to grant
them an interview or at least a comment
and he just kept he hired them in and he
fired them that's what he did you want
to look for my company come here you
[ __ ] you're fired get out of here yes
how long how long has this business
business business be no business at
least nine years right yeah and it in
2014 you know how people say like
running a business is risky I think
having a job is just as risky because
you you don't know if your boss is gonna
go crazy and like Colston drop with the
startup is risky or like a mom-and-pop
is risky that's true being is secure
though no matter what like you can be a
doctor you could be a lawyer like
nothing is true that's rich remember um
silent mic so we have a friend Simon
Mike he introduced me to one of his
friends that worked at Reebok and the
one that works at bands now I'll get
over here so like you would think my
Reeboks giant company which it is she
actually worked for Adidas which is
owned by Reebok which luckily don't know
and I think they were trying to make
separate moves branding moves like
Adidas and take over the soccer space
Reeboks him to take over the alternative
sports and then also they're like moving
marketing dollars around and because her
inner management was tight her
management let her know like hey we're
gonna have a huge layoff so before that
even happened by three months in advance
she already started submitting resumes
everywhere else and I'm getting a job at
fans and then when she got the job she
quit later on finding out that her whole
department that she was working with all
got laid off so even a big company like
that it's like it's kind of
unpredictable sometimes you know what
hello [ __ ] Shady there's a company
out there that that makes cars call
Boyata
and my friend he's my friend's parents
worked for them for like over 20 years
right and he decided to move their
headquarters to
rexis America I mean yeah
the state of rexis in Mexico and then
what happened there is there was rumors
going around where they're like hey if
you want to stick with the company will
give you a place to live just come along
for the journey or whatever right and
then people were like we should find a
different job because I heard that a lot
of companies they bet use lived there
for like a year and then they [ __ ]
kind of lay you off yeah so my friend's
mom was like I'm gonna I'm gonna find a
different job and social yep
the whole company moves over people that
decided to relocate all that [ __ ] after
a couple years they all got laid off so
they're all [ __ ] stuck there they
moved all their stuff Mexico and I was
like that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] dude
because there was at least in Texas were
way better
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]